Speaker 1: I have a number of things I want
to go over with you today, and the first one
is a really strange reason to oppose helping
homeless people. This is just bizarre
in the state of Tennessee. They've been debating
a bill dealing with homelessness. And in the midst
of the debate, Republican State Senator Frank
nicely stood up. He's from Strawberry Plains,
Tennessee, and he said, Hey, you know what?
Being homeless isn't the end of the world.
Hitler. Hitler was able to do things and make
something of himself, even after being homeless
for a little while. Now he's not saying killing
Jews is good, but why do you go to Hitler as an
example of someone who entered the history
books after being homeless? It's bizarre.
Speaker 2: I haven't given you all a history
lesson and a while, and I want to give you a
little history on homelessness, please. Not 10
and 10. Hitler decided to live on the streets
for a while, so for two years, Hitler lived on the
streets and practices or in his body language and
how to connect with Jews, and then went
on to lead our life after got him in the
history book. So a lot of these people, it's
not a dead end. They can come out of this,
these homeless camps and have a productive life,
or, in Hitler's case, a very unproductive life.
Speaker 1: A guy that I get is not saying, you
know, it was delightful. Hitler was homeless,
and then he came out and he was able to kill
six million Jews. I get that. He's not saying
that. But why do you have to point to Hitler? And
also, if Hitler chose to be homeless in order to
practice his oratory skills and and body language?
Most homeless people, they're not trying to build
public speaking skills by, by being homeless
mention, you know, the singer jewel at one
point was really living in her car. She really was
horrible back story to it or actor Jim Carrey once
lived in his car on his sister's front lawn.
And that's not even really being homeless in
the sense that a lot of people are homeless or
why? Why Hitler? And it's this very strange.
It's not an obsession, but it's like, why? Why
are they thinking of Hitler so much to make
positive points? And here the point is, listen,
it's not that bad to be in these homeless camps.
People can end up in the history books
even after being homeless. Look at Hitler.
These people are very strange, and I think that
there's something extraordinarily wrong with them